so this film was made in a time of great
protest and activism which you obviously
display in the film itself what how was
the film used did you show it to anyone
of the government was it was it used in
a way without reach to help spread the
word around you know laws and movements
around access to AIDS Medicaid
medication parades HBO did a big
screening in Washington and invited
everybody you know the whole Senate and
the House of Representatives I don't
know how many people came is it the
Kennedy you Center there's the Kennedy
Center it was a big deal and they all a
lot of them came a lot of house a lot of
reps and Senators and Vito know that was
a big night because very big because
they you know again obviously the the
power of this is how the quilt humanizes
it and visualizes the grief in a way
that you know just talking about I can't
do so you know senators and
congresspeople and the people that work
for them saw this and were moved just
like any human being is and it hopefully
did some good I think the the big effect
that it had though was really people
watching it on TV because HBO was you
know going into places that you know
where people would not go to watch a
film about AIDS you know this was this
was bringing it to them and the fact
that it was an HBO production gave it
some credibility and we you know
anecdotally we got dozens of letters
from P and written handwritten letters
back in the days before before email
yeah some of them were typewritten no
I'm saying
anyway that was that was very gratifying
and then when it won the Oscar we got a
major effect
I think socially well there's one
particular letter
you know that men still mean so much to
us
a young woman wrote to say that she had
a gay brother who has AIDS and her
father had disavowed her brother and
hadn't spoken to him in years and they
watched the film together and after
watching the film he got up and picked
up the phone and called her brother his
son so back to the personal I mean from
from the huge event that HBO did which
was huge to that very personal which was
so much in keeping with the spirit of
the quilt that that meant so much to us